أولاً، لنبدأ بهذا التصعيد الدراماتيكي الجديد
في الشرق الأوسط،
ضربات الرئيس بايدن ضد
المتمردين الحوثيين الداعمين لإيران في اليمن،
قالت عضوة الكونجرس التقدمي جايا بال، إنه كان
ينبغي للرئيس أن يحصل على
إذن من الكونجرس ويحتاج إليه في الواقع،
واصفًا الضربات بأنها انتهاك غير مقبول لـ
الدستور، هل
تتفق معها فيما إذا كانت هذه الضربات
غير قانونية؟ حسنًا، ما أعتقده هو أن
الرئيس لديه الحق في الرد على
أساس طارئ على
تعطيل الشحن الدولي
الناجم عن أصحاب القلنسوة، ومن ناحية أخرى،
يجب عليه الحصول على موافقة الكونجرس
على الفور  إن الكونجرس هو من له
الحق في إعلان الحرب وليس رئيس
الولايات المتحدة، لذا آمل أن
تصل هذه القضية إلى الكونجرس على الفور،
فلنتحدث عن الحرب التي تشنها إسرائيل
في غزة، فأنت تحاول فرض تصويت
في الكونجرس من شأنه أن يوجه الحرب.
وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية للنظر في ما إذا كانت
إسرائيل تستخدم لنا معدات أو
مساعدة أه لانتهاك معايير حقوق الإنسان
في غزة رد المتحدث باسم
مجلس الأمن القومي جون كيربي
على خطتك قائلا نقلا عن ذلك
لا نعتقد أن هذا القرار
هو الوسيلة الصحيحة ل  معالجة هذه
القضايا، ونحن لا نعتقد أن الآن هو
الوقت المناسب الذي أشار فيه الإسرائيليون إلى أنهم
يستعدون لنقل
عملياتهم إلى كثافة أقل بكثير،
ونعتقد أن هذا الانتقال سيكون
مفيدًا سواء من حيث تقليل
الخسائر في صفوف المدنيين أو
زيادة عدد الضحايا.  المساعدة الإنسانية،
ما الذي تقوله
لذلك، أنا لا أوافق بشدة، علينا أن نفعل ذلك،
بينما يأخذ الأمريكيون نفسًا عميقًا،
ما يحدث في غزة الآن هو
كارثة إنسانية مروعة،
فنحن ننظر إلى
23000 شخص قتلوا
تقريبًا  لقد أصيب 60,000
شخص وثلثي
القتلى هم من النساء والأطفال. أنت
تنظر إلى 70% من الوحدات السكنية في
غزة التي تم تدميرها. جاك إذا
استخدمت كلمة "يرتدون ملابس في ألمانيا"،
فإنك تفكر في الأمر المروع.  الدمار الذي لحق
بتلك المدينة أثناء الحرب العالمية الثانية، ما
يحدث في غزة الآن خلال 3 أشهر
أسوأ مما حدث في دريسدن
خلال عامين. هذه
كارثة والآن وفقًا
للأمم المتحدة بعد أن أصبح لديك 1.9
مليون شخص مشردين  من
منازلهم ليس لديهم طعام ليس
لديهم ماء ليس لديهم
معدات طبية ليس لديهم وقود ما
تنظرون إليه هو مجاعة وشيكة
الأطفال يتضورون جوعا حتى الموت لذلك
كان رأيي منذ البداية إسرائيل
يحق لك الرد على هذا
الهجوم الإرهابي المروع من كاماس، لكن
ليس لديك الحق في خوض حرب ضد
شعب بأكمله من النساء والأطفال، وعلى
الكونغرس الأمريكي أن يتحرك
لأن الكثير من هذا الدمار
يحدث بالجيش.  الأسلحة التي
قدمتها الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
والقرار الذي
أقدمه يتوافق
مع قانون المساعدة الأجنبية الذي ينص على
أنه إذا تم تقديم المساعدة العسكرية الأمريكية
لأي دولة، المملكة العربية السعودية، إسرائيل،
أي دولة أخرى، فيجب استخدامها  بما
يتوافق مع
المعايير الدولية لحقوق الإنسان والقانون
الأمريكي، في رأيي،
ليس هذا هو الحال بالتأكيد، فلدينا
كارثة إنسانية مروعة لا
يمكننا أن ندير ظهورنا لها.
يجب على الكونجرس أن يتوقف عن التحرك لحماية الأطفال
في
فلسطين